i love you
[Applause]
thanks for letting me stay awhile how
hard was it to say goodbye really really
hard
two of the best people to do it i think
to people who like comported themselves
so well during their time there
made it a better place to work you know
uplifted people
we're going to fire island and this is
why straight people hate us if i were
going to fire island in my speedo what
would be in my survival kit it has to
fit in the speedo no it doesn't have to
fit in the speedo i'm just going to i'm
just going to be in my speedo a fanny
pack a fanny backpack i was going to say
a bluetooth speaker you take it to the
beach with you play some tunes or you
can bring it back to the house a book
you can read that will inspire you to
write a movie based on that book i can't
believe you talked me into this again
let's give et canada a little t what was
the wildest thing that happened on fire
island how chemically specific yeah
listen baby this is in canada you tell
me the tea and we are going to put it
out there i think he was probably doing
lsd
and actually watching a house
inland during the actual physically
be lifted and moved and this is not the
lsd talking we actually witnessed that
we saw it happen and we weren't we had
we questioned our own reality and went
did that house just move
and um and it did and it did what are we
gonna like hug and wrap this up how does
this end